were you surprised by the outcome of the
tolly investigation to Dominic Rob where
two bullying complaints were upheld
against him did it surprise you no
because as we're discussing he was a
tough boss and when tough is the
everyday setting uh it's not a surprise
that that person oversteps the line and
clearly and at least one case Mr Rob
overstepped the line
so did you given the nature of how you
saw him operate
think that it would
escalate if you like what was tough
maybe back in when when were you working
with him in 20 19 to 20 19 to 20 that it
would build into something a bit more
that was what you felt that if he wasn't
kept in check well one aspect was
um talking to him about his impact the
impact of his behavior on the people
around him and I did that they were not
easy conversations but I I wanted him to
see that how he was treating the people
around him was affecting the outcomes
that was affecting his productivity his
delivery and he resisted that okay and
he consistently resisted that so you
raised his behavior with him before it
got to the stage of of bullying
um but he didn't accept your
what you would say constructive
criticism or advice
correct and Dominic Raab is a lawyer and
so everything was subject to quite
forensic analysis so a general
conversation was not a successful
conversation so just to be clear Simon
you're saying that more genius civil
servants said to you I'm finding working
for Mr Rob really difficult there's this
has happened all that's happened please
can you talk to him about it but don't
mention me and you tried to relay that
and he didn't accept that that's correct
okay were you surprised that he didn't
accept that or dismayed
they've made because
I think that
he was in control of his behaviors I
think he could have changed his
behaviors and he chose not to change his
behaviors did you like working with him
that's my answer he didn't
you don't have to what I mean you don't
want to answer whether a permanent
secretary likes working for a minister
is beside the point
um because our job is to help our
political boss deliver and Simon you you
talk about
um trying to talk to him informally
reflecting some of the concerns from
your your team
um you say that he deflected complaints
because he didn't have specific names
and examples you've explained why do you
looking back on it now regret not
escalating it yourself before it got
worse before it got to a stage when you
read the report did you think oh maybe I
should have done more
um
I did reflex because I never use the
word bullying in my conversations with
him but at the time it felt as though we
were trying to avoid that level given
what happened in my year with him uh you
know I feel uneasy but I still
understand what I did do you think he
should apologize for his behavior now
yes you do and well you just made that
he didn't
yes
okay now
he didn't apologize and actually there's
been lots of discussion over the weekend
about what the case means for the
relationship between the Civil Service
and government ministers and Dominic Rob
has got his view across very clearly
with a series of op-eds he's done for
newspapers he did a couple of interviews
he's written a very clear resignation
letter in which he said the outcome such
a dangerous president's precedence for
good government and encourages spurious
complaints against other
ministers
what do you think of that
I disagree with all of that
I think anybody who reads the report
will see that the threshold is a high
threshold and so
most people most people who have a bad
day don't have anything to worry about
because if you have a bad day you
recognize it you apologize to the person
you've interacted badly with and you
move on and as far as I can see there
will be no Stampede of such complaints
so I uh we'll see but I think he's wrong
about that and I think he's he's wrong
about the Civil Service I think the
civil service is it defines Itself by
its impartiality defines Itself by how
hard it works for government ministers
and in another part of his reaction Mr
Rob does pay tribute to many indeed most
of the civil servants he worked for Rory
Stewart whose political career saw him
work as a civil servant and later as
such state for International Development
said in recent days on on his podcast
that he quote did frequently find times
where people civil servants were
deliberately blocking him I mean this is
part of Rob's criticism wasn't it that
he felt that there was an activism
within the Civil Service that were
trying to block him and then trying to
oust him and and there's another you
know Minister there Rory Stewart who's
saying the same thing
I think that um
ministers are frustrated by aspects of
the Civil Service they are frustrated
that they don't immediately get the
points they are frustrated when action
doesn't happen as quickly as they want
you do not need to intimidate or
humiliate or threaten stuff in order to
shift the system the system I think has
on balance delivered for the United
Kingdom the ahead of the Civil Service
law cars Lake warned today that the
Prime Minister needs to speak out
against the torrent of invective against
the Civil Service
I agree I think the Prime Minister who
is also the minister for the Civil
Service uh he knows the Civil Service he
is surrounded by civil servants in
number 10 and the cabinet office he
knows their ethos uh he knows their
quality so I hope that the Prime
Minister and other ministers do publicly
recognize that what I saw in his
acceptance letter of Mr Rob was immense
sympathy with Mr Robb as Mr Robb railed
against the Civil Service I think I
would distinguish sharply if I were the
Prime Minister between personal sympathy
with a colleague I'd worked well with I
liked and uh systemic sympathy I think
the system is is uh needs a closer
closer attention than just accepting Don
Robb's word let me let me put another
way you concerned that if ministers and
the Prime Minister doesn't come out to
kind of stick up for the Civil Service
that the civil service will be unfair
fairly vilified by all of this that is a
possibility because one aspect is the
Silence of civil servants that a debate
can rage about them without any serving
Civil Service participation so that I
think is an unfair debate and that is
another reason for me as a retired civil
servant to speak out because I work for
the civil service for 38 years the
characterization given by Mr Rob I think
is flat wrong